très rapidement si on regarde sur les
réseaux sociaux et le bien-être je
voulais simplement vous montrer ces deux
études elles sont intéressantes elles
sont tirées exactement de la même base
de données ces deux études tirées de la
même base de données qui est une énorme
base de données qui est disponible sur
des données américaines et anglaises ou
quand vous Colliez l'ensemble de ces
données vous avez accès à 500000 données
d'adolescents qui peuvent lier le temps
qu'il passe sur les réseaux sociaux et
leur bien-être et on peut évaluer
différentes dimensions du bien-être et
si vous regardez tout ça dans les deux
cas vous avez autissez au même constat
il y a un lien significatif entre les
deux mais qui est de l'ordre de 0,4% du
bien-être expliqué par le temps passé
devant les réseaux sociaux je répète
0,4%
. et dans un cas à gauche
l'étude conclue à dire que dans ces
cas-là il n'y a pas d'urgence d'une
certaine manière en termes de santé
publique l'autre étude qui observe
exactement la même chose vous dit qu'il
y a donc une urgence en termes de santé
publique
donc c'est là où nous en sommes
aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire que sur la même
base de données vous avez deux
conclusions qui aboudissent finalement
statistiquement à la même conclusion
mais qui va ensuite en termes de
qu'est-ce que ça pose comme
problématique en termes de santé
publique arriver à des conclusions
radicalement différentes
ces deux études globalement ce qu'elle
recherche c'est est-ce qu'il existe un
lien entre le temps que vous passez sur
les réseaux sociaux enfin que les
adolescents passent sur les réseaux
sociaux pardon et le bien-être ressenti
par ces adolescents ces deux études vous
faites tourner des modèles statistiques
plus ou moins complexes mais globalement
ce qu'elle ce à quoi elles aboutissent
quel que soit ses études là c'est que
globalement le temps passé devant les
réseaux sociaux explique 0,4% du
bien-être des adolescents ou de la
variations du bien-être des adolescents
mais les deux concluent à la même chose
à gauche vous avez une chercheuse qui
disent ben si c'est 0,4 % il n'y a pas
de problématique de santé publique et
des chercheurs à droite qui vous disent
s'il y avait 0,4 %, c'est donc un
problème de santé publique sa boîte je
conclue pas là dessus c'est à vous de
conclure je vous dis simplement que on
en est là aussi c'était même avec des
données qui sont basées objectiver et
sur les mêmes bases de données on arrête
on arrive à des
conclusions radicalement différentes
pour ce qui est relève des réseaux
sociaux et des difficultés
psychologiques si on regarde de 1990 à
2017 on n'a pas d'explosion
contrairement à ce qu'on peut entendre
je sais d'un certain collectifs donc que
je nommerai pas il y a pas d'explosion
des difficultés
relatives au bien-être des adolescents
quand on regarde un certain nombre de
modèles statistiques un peu complexe
sur des bases de données qui sont des
bases de données qui sont consolidées de
ce point de vue là c'est là qu'on est
sur des très grosses bases donc entre
1990 et 2017 vous avez pas d'explosion
des difficultés psychologiques
rencontrées par les adolescents du fait
et encore une fois ça ne serait qu'une
corrélation du fait de l'émergence de
plus de numérique dans leur vie
quotidienne
c'est une corrélation globale et j'y
viens
vous avez entièrement raison donc une
des choses qu'on peut essayer de faire
aussi c'est de se poser la question
finalement de se dire qu'est-ce qui se
passe quand on regarde dans un
échantillon un peu plus restreint si
vous regardez au cours du temps sur
plusieurs semaines la variation du
bien-être des adolescents en fonction du
temps qu'il passe sur les réseaux
sociaux est-ce que là vous pouvez
trouver des associations vous trouvez
des associations c'est ce que montre ce
diagramme en bas de cette diapositive
mais ce que vous voyez c'est que on a
deux informations différentes quand on
regarde en intra-individuel c'est pour
un individu donné la variation du temps
qu'il passe sur l'écran et la variation
de son bien-être on a plutôt un effet de
plus il passe du temps sur les écrans
plus on a une diminution de son
bien-être c'est très relatif c'est en
quelques pour cent et que paradoxalement
pour ceux qui dépassent plus de 3 à 4
heures de temps passé ces réseaux
sociaux on a une augmentation du
bien-être donc c'est même pas linéaire
en termes de temps qu'on passe devant
ces écrans-là c'est-à-dire qu'on voit
qu'au sein quand on prend les extrêmes
de la distribution ici on a les 1% les
plus extrêmes de la distribution qui
passent le plus de temps sur les réseaux
sociaux eux pour chaque heure en plus
qu'il passe devant les réseaux sociaux
on a un bien-être associé qui augmente
et si vous regardez en inter individuel
j'essaye de rentrer dans toute la
complexité de ces données si vous
regardez entre les individus à ce moment
là quand vous êtes sur les 5% qui
consomment le plus
les 95% de la population excusez moi qui
regarde des écrans chaque heure passait
entre 0 et 2 heures sur les écrans à
plus et plutôt associé à une
augmentation du bien-être
donc globalement on peut pas je dirais
d'une certaine manière conclure de façon
absolue dans un sens ou dans un autre
pour dire il y a des efforts extrêmement
négatifs de ces réseaux sociaux ou
extrêmement positif c'est ni l'un ni
l'autre c'est toute façon des effets
extrêmement faibles et là où je vous
rejoins qui vont dépendre en fait
fondamentalement des prédispositions
psychologiques de ces adolescents en
fait si on regarde l'adolescence comme
une population où les adolescents comme
une population homogène on se trompe
dans le constat que nous faisons parce
qu'effectivement ces réseaux sociaux
seront finalement des amplificateurs de
difficultés psychologique préexistantes
chez l'adolescent et c'est ça la
complexité qu'on va avoir c'est à dire
que quand vous regardez par exemple ce
qui peut se passer sur un réseau social
en termes de comparaison sociale si vous
avez une bonne estime de vous-même et
que vous allez sur un réseau social et
que vous vous rentrez dans une situation
de comparaison sociale ça va plutôt
avoir un effet positif sur votre estime
de vous si vous venez avec une estime de
vous qui est négative ou mauvaise vous
allez sur un réseau social cette
comparaison sociale va aboutir à une
diminution de votre estime de soi